COURSE PAID RIGHT NOW, THE
PRESIDENT'S TALKING LOCAL
POLITICS BUT WE WILL GET BACK TO
HIM SHORTLY.
AS PROMISED THOUGH, THERE'S A
LOT TO UNPACK FROM THE
DEMOCRATIC DEBATE LAST NIGHT.
FOUR YEARS AGO, DEMOCRATS CAME
UP WITH A NEW AND UNTESTED
POLITICAL THEORY, THEY COULD WIN
THE WHITE HOUSE, THEIR
STRATEGIST PROMISED, IF ONLY
THEY CALLED ENOUGH PEOPLE
RACIST.
THAT WAS THE PLAN.
HILLARY CLINTON, PHONE, THOUGHT
IT WAS BRILLIANT.
BY ELECTION DAY, SHE HAD
ANNOUNCED HALF THE COUNTRY AS
BIGOTS.
IN THE END, IT DIDN'T WORK, THEY
WOULD NOT SURPRISE ME, TURNS OUT
THAT WHEN YOU TELL PEOPLE YOU
HATE THEM, THEY DON'T CARE FOR
IT.
WHAT VOTERS STRONGLY PREFER A
COMEBACK SHOULD IS WHEN YOU TRY
TO IMPROVE THEIR LIVES.
IT'S NOT COMPLICATED.
YET, SOMEHOW, THIS IS THE
REMARKABLE PART, IF YOU THINK
ABOUT IT, DEMOCRATS HAVE, IN THE
THREE YEARS SINCE THEY LOST,
STEADFASTLY REFUSED TO LEARN
THIS LESSON.
IMPROVE PEOPLE'S LIVES, THEY
WILL TELL YOU?
NO THANKS.
THEY THINK THEIR JOB IS TO
IMPROVE PEOPLE.
THEY THINK VOTERS ARE DISGUSTING
AND IMMORAL.
THEY WANT TO FORCE THEM TO BE
HALF AS VIRTUOUS AS THEY ARE.
FOR THE SECOND ELECTION CYCLE IN
A ROW, THAT IS THE DEMOCRATIC
MESSAGE.
YOU ARE DISGUSTING, TRY TO BE AS
GOOD AS WE ARE.
THAT MESSAGE WAS ON FLOOR OF
DISPLAY LAST NIGHT OF THE
CANDIDATE'S DEBATE.
TO PICK AMONG COUNTLESS EXAMPLES
OF IT, WASHINGTON
GOVERNOR JAY INSLEE BRAINS
AMERICANS FOR THE COMING END OF
THE WORLD.
>> WE CANNOT WORK IT OUT HERE WE
CANNOT WORK THIS OUT.
THE TIME IS UP HERE TO OUR HOUSE
IS ON FIRE.
WE HAVE TO STOP USING COAL IN
TEN YEARS AND WE HAVE A
PRESIDENT THAT WON'T GET THAT
DONE TO GET OFF COAL.
SAVE THIS COUNTRY AND THE
PLANET.
THAT'S WHAT I'M ON BOARD FOR IT.
>> Tucker: OKAY, SO LET'S TAKE
CARBON EMISSIONS REALLY ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR IT WILL BECOME
THE CHANGE BUT WE DON'T KNOW
THAT.
SCIENCE HAS NOT PROVED IT.
SORRY.
IT IS NOT PROVEN.
BUT JUST FOR THE SAKE OF
ARGUMENT, LET'S SPECULATE THAT
IT'S TRUE.
CARBON CAUSE OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
CHINA HAS BY FAR THE WORLD'S
BIGGEST EMITTER OF CARBON.
SO SHOULDN'T GOVERNOR INSLEE,
WHO CARES VERY DEEPLY ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE, TURN HIS WRATH
ON THE CHINESE?
WILL COME OF COURSE.
BUT HE DIDN'T.
AND NEVER WILL.
BECAUSE FOR DEMOCRATS, IS ALWAYS
DEFAULT OF AMERICANS VOTERS.
KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND OF NEW YORK
BRAGGED ABOUT THAT TIME SHE
BRINGS SOME OF THE TOURISTS MOST
DEAF RICK PEOPLE IN AMERICA
ABOUT BEING TOO PRIVILEGE.
EVEN AS THEY LANGUISH IN CHRONIC
UNEMPLOYMENT AND DROPPED DEAD BY
THE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS FROM A
WIDELY IGNORED DRUG EPIDEMIC HAD
THE REAL PROBLEM IS THEIR WHITE
PRIVILEGE.
>> I DON'T BELIEVE THAT IT'S THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF COREY AND,
LIKE TO BE THE ONLY VOICE THAT
TAKES ON THESE ISSUES OF
INCIDENT INSTITUTIONAL RACISM.
I THINK AS A WHITE WOMAN OF
PRIVILEGE WHO IS A U.S. SENATOR
RUNNING AS THE AS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
IT IS ALSO MY RESPONSIBILITY TO
LIFT UP THOSE VOICES THAT ARE
BEING LISTENED TO AND I CAN TALK
TO THOSE WHITE WOMAN IN THE
SUBURBS AND TALK TO THEM ABOUT
WHAT WHITE PRIVILEGE ACTUALLY
IS.
MY RESPONSIBLE IS NOT TO ONLY
LIFT UP THOSE STORIES BUT
EXPLAINED TO COMMUNITIES ACROSS
AMERICA LIKE I DID IN OHIO, TO A
YOUNG MOTHER, DOES THIS IS ALL
OF OUR RESPONSIBILITY.
>> Tucker: YEAH, THEY ARE
PRIVILEGE.
JUST TOO MUCH PRIVILEGE GRADE
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
NOT TO BE OUTDONE, JULIAN CASTRO
ATTACHED AMERICANS FOR DARING TO
COMPLAIN ABOUT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION TO THEIR COUNTRY.
OPEN BORDERS?
THAT'S JUST A RIGHT WING TALKING
POINT.
AND THEN A SINGLE BREATH LATER,
CASTRO CALLED FOR APPEALING A
LAW THAT MAKES IT A CRIME TO
ENTER AMERICA ILLEGALLY.
WATCH.
>> OPEN BORDERS IS A WHITE RING
TALKING POINT AND FRANKLY, AND
DISAPPOINTED THAT SOME FOLKS ON
THIS STAGE HAVE TAKEN THE
DEBATE.
THE ONLY WAY THAT WE ARE GOING
TO GUARANTEE THAT WE DON'T HAVE
BRADLEY'S SEPARATIONS IN THIS
SET COUNTRY AGAIN IS TO RIP PEEL
THE IMMIGRATION AND NATIONALITY
ACT.
>> Tucker: AND CORY BOOKER AND
THEN THAT MEANWHILE IS IN THE
PROCESS OF TRANSITIONING TO A
BRAND-NEW IDENTITY.
HE SPENT MOST OF THE INNING
SOUNDING LIKE A NATION OF ISLAM
RECRUITER RATHER THAN A DEEPLY P
RECRUITER RATHER THAN A DEEPLY I
RECRUITER RATHER THAN A DEEPLY E
SON OF TWO IVY AND EXECUTIVES
WHICH IS WHAT HE REALLY IS.
>> THERE ARE PEOPLE RIGHT NOW IN
PRISON FOR LIFE FOR DRUG
OFFENSES BECAUSE YOU STOOD UP
AND USED THAT TOUGH ON CRIME
PHONY ILLITERATE THAT GOT A LOTO
PHONY ILLITERATE THAT GOT A LOTF
PEOPLE ELECTED BUT DESTROYED
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE.
>> Tucker: MR. BOOKER, BARKING
AT THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT.
POOR VICE PRESIDENT.
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE THAT WERE
DESTROYED BY YOU, JOE BIDEN.
CORY BOOKER DREW GREW UP IN A
HERE INCHING PARK NEW JERSEY
PEER THE BLACK POPULATION OF
PARENTING PART?
0.6%.
LESS THAN 1%.
THE POVERTY RATE FOR FAMILIES IN
HARRINGTON PARK?
LITERALLY ZERO.
NOT A SINGLE FAMILY IN
HARRINGTON PARK IS POOR.
NOT ONE.
THAT'S WHERE COOK HORI
CORY BOOKER GROUT.
SO THE ONLY WAY THAT JOE BIDEN'S
CRIME POLICY IS DISTORTED IN HIS
HOMETOWN IS BY ALLOWING
PRESIDENTS TO MOVE OUT AND
GENTRIFIED BROOKLYN.
CORY BOOKER IS BY FAR THE MOST
PRIVILEGED CANDIDATE RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT IN EITHER PARTY THIS
YEAR AND THAT'S FINE, NOT HIS
FAULT.
IT'S THE RELENTLESS LYING ABOUT
IT THAT SO DEGRADING.
CAN ANY OF THESE CANDIDATES WIN
A GENERAL ELECTION?
IN IT AT THIS POINT, NO CARE
THEY CAN'T PAY THEY ARE NOT
IMPRESSIVE ENOUGH.
JOE BIDEN WAS THE PARTIES ONE
REAL HOPE AND AFTER LAST NIGHT,
IT SEEMS PRETTY CLEAR
CONCLUSIVELY CLEAR, REALLY, THAT
UNCLE JOE IS HEADING FOR A WELL
RESERVED RETIREMENT.
>> THE FACT IS, THE BILLS THAT
THE PRESIDENT, THE FUTURE
PRESIDENT, THAT THE SENATOR IS
TALKING ABOUT, IF YOU AGREE WITH
ME, GO TO JOE, 30330 AND HELP ME
IN THIS FIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> Tucker: BITING COULDN'T
EVEN LOCATE HIS OWN CAME PAN
WEBSITE THAT JOE 30330 WEBSITE?
IT DOESN'T EXIST.
IN FACT, I THINK IT'S BEEN
BOUGHT BY PETE BUTTIGIEG OR
SOMETHING.
WHAT IT TELLS YOU A LOT ABOUT
JOE BIDEN.
DON'T BE FOOLED BY THE CURRENT
POLL NUMBERS.